hello i'm gerard medioni i'm a vice
president distinguished scientist at
amazon
i'm also an emeritus professor at usc
and what i want to share with you today
is my personal journey
of uh more than 40
years
in the computer vision field
so
without introduction
let's uh let's start
i'm gonna do it in uh three chapters
uh we'll start with the academic part
then with the startups and then with my
current position which is at amazon and
those are not quite sequential because
my academic
life and my involvement with startups
are overlapping
so let's uh let's start
it's important to kind of give you first
of all a a brief timeline i talked about
40 years that u.s
40 years well it has been 40 years at
usc
uh
inbred
in the sense that i was a student at usc
then i became a professors and i became
chair of the computer science department
and then
i became emeritus in 2019
so
just to give you this timeline
approximately since 1979 is when i came
from france
to the us
i graduated in 1983 and then you see
this timeline
right there
and you can find a lot of my
work through my papers during that time
what is less known
is the non-academic part which is a
chapter 2 which is
started pretty much
early 1994
and uh with a number of companies
and the the the reason i was involved
with this
most of them are startups
is
because i'm not the ivory tower type of
professor
where you invent the problems and you
solve it and then you ask if anybody
cares but instead going
to companies and finding
interesting problems that are not solved
because there is a core science problem
to be solved
so
uh let's start chapter one
usc
just to give you a
little bit of context here
computer vision
is a young field
uh it started in the 1960s
one of the early
uh
a person was at mit
and uh roberts larry roberts
is the the person who really
created the first
computer vision
papers
uh if you look for larry roberts by the
way you're not going to find much about
his
his computer vision except his thesis he
went on
to really be one of the founders of the
internet at the time called the opponent
okay
so
being in a field in the early days
is very exciting why is it exciting
because you don't know what you don't
know
so it presents both a set of
opportunities
and of course a set of challenges and
i'll talk about some of them but it has
to do with well how do you get the data
to start with
second
you're not working in a in a silo
isolated in your lab
you need to communicate and compare the
results
and you need to ask a question you know
how fast can we solve the these problems
and you face this explorer's dilemma
which is you don't even know what
problems need to be solved
and
you find a problem you you say well i
should work on it then you should ask
the question is it a relevant problem
and what are the potential solutions
and finally
when you have enough
maturity into the solution you want to
ask well how can we transition this to
real world applications
so
let's
talk about the data
i was fortunate to have joined
the usc image processing institute
and this was where all the data at the
time this is where it originated
you are probably familiar with lina
which is a the picture on the right
which was used by
everybody in the early days to test
algorithm
so how did we get the image in the first
place
this image comes from a magazine
and
there was no
easy way to capture the image except by
scanning
scanning it how do you do it you use a
drum image scanner which means you put
the image on a on a cylinder
and then it is being
scanned
by a
point scanner
for every point you get a rgb rgb value
this is a very long and painful process
it takes uh
closer to an hour to get a decent
picture out
so let's say you have an image
uh how do you
share it with anybody
well
you have a file
you need to figure out what it is there
was no standard header there was no
nothing like that so for example if you
get a 65
664 byte that means it's probably a 256
by 256
image with a 128 header
you look at it and if it's noise then
you say well maybe it was a
a 512 by
by
128 instead
the other thing you need to realize with
this data
is
that you need to store it somewhere and
it's very very very expensive
the storage at the time in 1980 for one
gigabyte was 40 000
so
uh the entry barrier to get into the
field of computer vision
was very high
in fact many of the papers that you see
from the early days
is for example tanks detection of tanks
or recognition of text works on 16 by 16
images because that's all you could fit
in memory
well let's compare it to what's
happening today
today we get 300 million photos that get
uploaded every day we get 300 hours of
video uploaded to youtube
every minute
so we went from a scarcity of data
to a deluge
of data so data is no longer really a
problem
today
and
let's talk about this scientific
communication and progress well
the way it worked in the early days is
everybody got their data set
you want to work on something well you
managed to get one picture two images
maybe
and then you write a paper well
you get a call can i can i have your
code so that i can replicate
uh you say well yes of course i'd be
happy to give it to you what what
what language are you using well i'm
using lisp oh i'm using fortran oh well
that's going to be a problem what
library where we don't have libraries we
don't have interfaces so the
communication was going through
conferences
and journals
and that means that the progress is
fairly slow because it takes
one to two years for paper from
submission to
to publication so very slow progress
it's instructive to look at what's
happening today today
we have
annotated data sets available for
everybody
we get papers on archive and they get
updated every day every day you have
something new
and you have code on github
so you can directly download and try
and see
uh and replicate the results so the
progress
instead of occurring on a six months or
yearly basis
is now occurring on a weekly basis
all right i talked about the explorer
dilemma so what is that what
so i give you an image and you say i
want to
know what it is well what blocks do we
build what what are the key components
one of them is you say well how does a
human visual system work and i know
there are there is
a
neurons that are that are very sensitive
to edges so we extract features we have
to find edges in images well yes i did
some so the other
similar thing instead of edges you could
try to do region segmentation
once you have these features you need to
group them
and you do that by linking merging
fitting
and again i did some of this work and
tensor voting is
my some of my papers
uh
in in this field
then you have high level reasoning which
is not just talk about features and and
groups of features but go all the way to
object recognition or 3d pose estimation
and again
in the early fields we did everything so
i did that
one other thing you can ask is
why do i need to stop at one image maybe
if i use two images
i can do better and then you say well we
have two eyes we can do stereo obviously
with two images it should be easier
or you can say well we don't process one
image
we get an image sequence so you get this
motion analysis and again that's another
direction in which we can go which is uh
image sequence analysis so if you start
building those blocks
you can start
building solutions to real problems
there is another direction which is to
say well you know we don't have to
necessarily replicate
the human visual system and do what
people do maybe we can simplify the
problem maybe we can restrict the domain
or we can use depth
so instead of having a regular camera we
can have
a depth camera
so let me show you some examples
uh
of these
ideas
so the first one
is going to be
well what if i have instead of a regular
camera or gb camera i have a camera that
gives us depth
so
and the rationale behind that is if
trying to get 3d from one image is so
hard
why not start with 3d
so i i built some early blogs to do that
including
icp the iterative closest point in 1992
which happened to be my most cited paper
and what it does is given two clouds of
points
how do you
make how do you align them
and
that's a fundamental problem
so
uh
in in in this simplification or in there
you see that
the application only appears decades
later
so for example this was in 1992 well in
2007
the defense
advanced research projected in cidarpa
created a program called urgent which is
urban reasoning and geospatial
exploration technology
which the goal was to find all the
components in a range image find the
roofs find the chimneys find the the
wires find all of these in there
another
advance was in 2010 the microsoft kinect
came and it was a revolution as it
offered a hundred dollar consumer
product and i'll talk about it later
because
um i was involved in in some of it
another example
uh you have all seen the the the famous
game where in the world is carmen san
diego
uh so what is it well imagine that
you're dropped off
you look around take pictures and you
need to answer the question
where in the world are you
so
uh you know that's one of the cases
where you invent a problem so in 1995 we
published with fridge stein
a map-based localization using the
panoramic horizon that is you look
around you extract the horizon line and
you say if i have this horizon line it's
actually unique and i can tell you where
this is taken where this picture was
taken from
uh it didn't get a great reception at
the time the comments were
why do you want to solve this problem
it's useless
just use gps and you have your solution
i had a good answer to that when i said
well what if you go on mars
you won't have gps on mars so
you still need to solve the problem
regardless so
2011 the
ir pub
created the finder program and what was
the final program is i give you
an image
or set of images and you're supposed to
tell me
where
in the world you were
which is exactly the geolocation test
of course at that time i got a number of
calls hey we have this we have read your
paper and now we need to actually put it
in practice so my citations shot up at
that time
okay so not just two examples of the
type of
uh application we we have
i want to talk about the next one right
here which is a
picture of me here wearing the device
and we created which is simply a a
camera it's just a
a a
camera right there
and what we wanted to do is produce
visual aids for the blind
why did we do this well because the the
two were starting to become mature
and uh
this is a
significant social impact to provide
navigation
aid for the blind
indoors both indoors and outdoors
a performing planning
and obstacle avoidance
so
we went to the braille institute in los
angeles
and uh we did a proof of concept we had
this vest
that you can see there
and the vest
had four little motors so whenever there
is an obstacle in front of you all four
motors will buzz and the person would
stop and then if the left motor bus that
means you should turn left if the right
motor bust you need to turn right
and the feedback from the
users
was outstanding this was great
but it was still a long way to a product
in fact i got a call
from a blind user
and she said to me you know when can i
buy it this is wonderful i need it when
can i can i buy it
and that's when i realized
you know
this is not the role of academic
research
this is not
what we are supposed to be doing
in academia
we need to interact with industry
and uh we need to find a different
channel to go from this
prototype to a product
so
i'm gonna move now to chapter two which
is exactly the motivation for this
which is uh how do you interact with
industry and what do you learn and not
all
lesson learned have to do with
technology as you will see
so
gave you the chapter one
uh which is a usc and the academic life
let's talk now
about the
chapter two which is our startups
so um
as i told you i will
i engage with
industry outside of academia very early
in the career and i will choose some of
these
um i'll talk about opticopy i'll talk
about abscess
and the lesson that i learned i'll talk
about geometrics big stage lesson prime
sense and then in the third chapter
we'll talk about uh invention at
amazon
so let's start with uh the key
point here
the point of disruptive technology
is uh you can look at it two ways one i
mean the good news is that it's
disruptive
the the bad news is that it is
disruptive so what does that mean
uh the good news is that it opens road
to new
opportunities but because it doesn't fit
to existing models
it's very hard to just take it and put
it in existing frameworks so it creates
these hurdles to adoptions so i'm going
to show you a number of examples of that
let's start with optical optic rp
is addressing a an interesting problem
which is the automatic registration
of half tone separations
so uh give you a little context here the
company was making state of the art
pre-press equipment
and they wanted to automate this
automatic registration
they tried a solution that didn't work
at the accuracy which was required and
then they they asked me for help
and i was a
fresh
assistant professor
and
naive as i was i said of course i can do
it
and so let me tell you what the problem
is
what is a half tone to start with well
if you start with film
film is essentially continuous i mean
you can see it here when you want to go
to print
to transform
the intensity
of the and let's go with a great tone
for now you transfer you encode the
intensity by the size of the dot
so if the size of the dot is zero then
it's white and if the side of the dot is
full
then uh it is uh
it is black
so that's how you go from one to the
other and here's an example on the
screen of different resolution of the
dot size
okay
so um
that's for black and white well how do
we do color
well we do color by using four different
screens
and each screen
encodes a different
color components
cyan magenta yellow and black
you may want to ask why we're using
three
four colors instead of three we know
that the human eye
is using
three sensors so why would we using four
and the answer is uh very simple is that
black ink
is cheaper than color ink therefore
you're trying to
cut the cost by using as much as
possible of the black so notice that
as
this
this um
screens
align
the eye is blending those colored dots
to create the illusion of a uniform
color so if you want to get
cyan you get this example right there if
you want to get
green
it's what it shows there okay
so the process is straightforward you
start with a color image
you create films
for different films
which encode
the content in each of these bands so
you can see right here what i'm
explaining is on the top is the
the continuous version and the bottom
is the
um
the digital one so you could take from
one color film you go to full film the
content is obviously different
because you have different content of
red green and blue in there
and when you align them you need a few
microns accuracy
so
i'm not going to tell you how we did it
but essentially
we
achieved great success from a technology
point of view um we were able to
register
10 sets an hour
four for humans and
we were more accurate than humans so
uh great tech achievement
and uh it was actually a very good
business achievement because given this
technology
a the whole company was sold
in 1987 to
polychrome
and it was really based on that
technology so it was a successful exits
so we have a
tech success we have a business success
uh a question is uh so what
and the answer is
by the time it was ready for
adoption the industry switched to
digital
making the technology completely
obsolete
so again why because when you're doing a
digital separation
you are by design preserving the
registration so if you go into photoshop
and you say give me a separation
cmy black you get it it's automatically
registered you don't need the technology
that i developed okay
so what is the lesson here
this is the first lesson it's an
important one
uh you need to keep aware of the global
context
and anticipate
the disruptive changes
which may disrupt your disruptive
technology
knowing your current competitive
landscape is not enough
so just knowing
who your competitors are is not enough
you need to project
advances in the field
all right
lesson number one
let's go to the second example which was
abscess
uh it's a real-time technology
to insert
a computer actuated content into a video
it needs to be absolutely seamless
so
used for virtual advertising it can use
for sports enhancement telling you what
the distance to the goal is
it could be used live it could be used
in post-production so
rather
to you here here's the example
so what you see here
is three different
broadcasts
whereas the
ads on the side
are different
we have replaced here
in the live video stream
we can replace
the ads
accordingly
so this is a
very exciting technology if you think
about it
it is nothing but the ancestor of the
10 yard yellow line that you see in
in american football today
that's what it so
uh
great technology
needed to solve some
really interesting problem in panorama
feature tracking object detection
image mapping lighting
augmented reality
it's a hard problem a real-time
constraint you need to start replacing
those billboards even when they are at
the edge
of the field of view
you cannot have any jitter and of course
you need to worry about occlusion
so
it worked
surprisingly enough
for some people the technology worked
actually very well
we deployed it for several high-profile
sports event i remember i was i was at a
an event in the south of france for a
formula one
and i could see the real
the real image and i could see the
replaced image and it was very exciting
it had the potential for a huge business
opportunity i mean
uh the word from the company we were
working for
working with at the time was we gonna
make hundreds of millions of dollars
visits and the dollars of course are
from the advertisers
well guess what
three companies failed trying to do this
it's surprising
uh so you want to ask well
why
why is why did it fail i mean you have
the technology that works
you have a market segment that is
should be attracted to it so why is it
uh first one is well how do you price it
you know when you sell a billboard you
say i'm paying you for the billboard
here you pay for what minutes on the
screen how can you guarantee that you
have that many minutes on the screen
uh the other one is well how do you
insert it in the chain where do you go
where do you get the input to start with
so
uh here's the way it worked is that you
go to the primary broadcaster who is on
on on
premise
and you say
i need to get access to your
to your tube right there and this is
sure
and the head takes a hand out and you're
gonna pay for it
then you go to the secondary broadcaster
and you say hey
you need to broadcast my feed and they
said no i don't have to broadcast your
feed i can broadcast the original feed
and you say okay here i'll pay you some
then
the league says wait a second this is a
league game
you can't do that
um and you say sure
and put your hand out i'll give you
something
then the teams say hey wait a second we
are the actors in here
we are on the stage
and you say sure put your hand out
and then you have the
stadium that says oh wait a second
when i sell
a
advertising panel
i get money and you say of course put
your hand out
and at the end
you know it's a very long chain of
uh handouts that you have to do along
the way way too many parties to the deal
so
uh who made money in all of this
is the people who actually put the deal
together
so
where is it today well today it's mostly
used in post-processing just like slow
motion
uh and the money from advertisers
no
really didn't make it
so we have here an example of a
technologies that succeed
but
again
technology without the business model
is doomed from the start you need to
proceed in parallel
every time i ask the question
what is a business model
the answer was don't worry we're going
to make hundreds of millions of dollars
well guess what
didn't happen so that was the second
lesson
so let's fast forward a few years
and let's talk about big stage
at usc
i had created a way to create a very
very accurate
face model
from
images
so
a company came and said we know how to
leverage that
we're gonna upload one or two or three
pictures and then we're going to create
this virtual
we can create personalized
ads personalized
cards personalized videos
and this was a
great idea hey i can actually replace
an actor
into a video clip
wow
it sounds what we what we call today
deep fake well
this is
uh the ancestor of the fake where you
actually put
a a
a
a new face
onto an existing one so
there are some very interesting problems
how do you deal with expression changes
uh eye movement and so on so what you
can do is you take a video stream a
video clip you can prepare it
and
you uh
with one click you can insert yourself
into it
we did it
i'm going to show you one example but we
did it if you go to that youtube link
which is right there
we
did it with
a michael jackson thriller a very short
video clip where people became
michael jackson
and in one week with no advertisement
nothing we got 3 000 people who became
michael jackson who replaced michael
jackson in srila
let me show you what we did with
professor george becky uh was a
professor at usc it was his 75th
birthday and a roast and what i did here
is i took this one picture
and i put george
in the movie so here it is
he's shot look like he's lost a lot of
blood doctors
really have to lighten up on this
paranoia they play dirty but we play
dirty
oh forever i love it when a plan comes
all right so you saw what it is it is
not
movie quality
but it is
youtube quality so this was the example
so again
um
uh
interesting story so
uh it worked
again
but
the company was raising a b round in
2008.
remember 2008
the financial crisis well
the company run out of money
and really the company never had a
business plan articulated
it was the same story whenever i asked
what is a business plan he said don't
worry we're going to make a lot of money
didn't happen
so
the other thing he tried to do is
he tried to monetize
by taking small projects he tried to
monetize the technology
before finishing the product and that
actually prevented the product from
being finished
so
the third lesson
is that you need to stay focused
you can't just
try to do other things while you're not
finishing the product so focus is
essential
but lesson four
is probably
very very actionable a product
is miles away from a prototype so do not
try to sell a prototype finish the
product and then you can you can
then you can sell it
but there is one more lesson
which is
timing
is a predominant factor for success
in fact there was a study by the harvard
business school
that listed all the potential factor and
correlated that to success of failure of
startups
and timing
is a number one factor
the bad news is that
most of the time a startup does not have
any
any control
or very little control over timing
okay
let's move on to prime sense as i was
presenting that you know
one of my colleagues said after all this
failure somebody is still willing to
hire you well i guess i guess the answer
is yes so prime sense
uh what is prime sense by sense decided
to create
a consumer-grade 3d image capture for
under a hundred dollars
and the idea was to use a body as a user
interface
mostly for gaming application
this was a very disruptive success
it revolutionized several fields
including robotics within six months of
the introduction
one-third of the papers in the robotics
conference
were
talking about using this device
as
as input
so
what does it look like well here it is
on the top left what you have is the
image of the prime sensor
what does it do well it works on the
principle of triangulation
you have an infrared light source
which is a
encoding
which has an encoding on it
and then
you have a processor and a sensor so you
are projecting
a invisible ir light
and by doing this triangulation
you are creating the depth image which
is on the on the right over there
we also had a regular rgb camera which
gave you the image right here
uh on the left so you you have the
the emitter
the receiver
processor
that gives you this
image writing now when you have that
you can fit an articulated model
to the people
and create a
avatar
in motion which is accurate and you can
use it for games you can hit a ball you
can you can catch you can box you can do
all this
gaming
processes
so
we built it
it was a great success
microsoft was a major customer
which uses it in the kinect one
and according to the guinness world
records book
it is even till today it is the world's
fastest selling consumer electronic
device ever
moving more than 10 million
system by march that means that every
day
we were selling 133
000 units
from november to january this was a mega
hit
and the company was
doing absolutely great at the time
but
there was a setback again there was a
number of reasons
uh microsoft wanted
to have their own solution as opposed to
a single supplier
so in 2012 we laid off
some of the employees
and
we tried to attempt to reinvent
the company instead of just saying well
let's just keep on improving the
technology so we come up with a low
footprint design
which is the capri
um
so
if you want to see what
the the white one right here
is the original proof of concept
this is the prime sensor
and this one was a reduced side
uh reduced size one that we came up with
uh that's a capri
uh well it was a successful exit
the company was sold to apple in
december 2013
for 330 million dollars
and if you have an iphone
and if you look at the the top of the
iphone the camera on it
is
on the iphone 10
it is a prime sensor
so that is the uh
that is the success of it
so this time
instead of giving you lessons of
what not to do i'll tell you the lessons
of what to do
so the key was uh you need to have a
bold vision
you need to think big
it was a high risk proposition there was
only three possible customers
and two of them said no and the third
one said yes
so it was a very high risk proposition
the company had a very strong leadership
both technically
and on the business side and it never
deviated from the business model which
is we need to sell the processor
and license the
manufacturing that's it
of course
the
we also needed the ability to adapt to
ambiguity and to change so uh
we knew what they what how what the end
goal was but were willing to adapt as we
went
so that's the lesson here
and
that takes me to the third chapter
which is
amazon
so
it has to do with invention
so i was approached i was
at the time
i was approached by
amazon to
work on something
which was secret
which was
a
revolutionary so that made it very
attractive to me of course
and
what is it what is this notion of
invention on behalf of customers at
amazon
it comes from as a very core
of the company which is captured in this
jeff bezos quote
it's not customer job to invent for
themselves
it is your job to invent on their behalf
you need to listen to customer they
won't tell you everything
therefore you need to invent on their
behalf and i'm going to try to
give you
two examples of that
notion of that principle right there
the first one has to go with
amazon go and this what we call the just
workout technology
so
um
for those of you who are not familiar
with it
uh let me show you the promo
videos a short promo video we had
at the time where it was unveiled
four years ago we started to wonder
what would shopping look like if you
could walk into a store grab what you
want and just go
what if we could weave the most advanced
machine learning computer vision and ai
into the very fabric of a store so you
never have to wait in line
no lines no checkouts no registers
welcome to amazon go
[Music]
use the amazon go app to enter
then put away your phone and start
shopping
it's really that simple take whatever
you like
anything you pick up is automatically
added to your virtual cart
if you change your mind about that
cupcake
just put it back
our technology will update your virtual
cart automatically
[Music]
so how does it work
we used computer vision deep learning
algorithms and sensor fusion much like
you'd find in self-driving cars
we call it just walk out technology
once you've got everything you want you
can just
go
when you leave our just walk out
technology adds up your virtual cart and
charges your amazon account your receipt
is sent straight to the app and you can
keep going
amazon go
[Music]
no lines no checkout no seriously
[Music]
all right so
why why did we build amazon go
what is the customer problem that we're
trying to address here
the customer problem i'm trying to
address here that we believe no one
likes waiting in line
there's been a number of innovation in
brick and mortar retail over the years i
mean you can think of
credit cards you can talk about
barcode scanning
self checkout station but fundamentally
the customer experience is still the
same you shop
then you wait in line to check out then
you pay then you leave
with this
what we with amazon go with just workout
technology we're changing the experience
as you saw you use the app to enter the
store you take whatever you want and you
just go
no lines no checkouts you just work out
okay
so it's a fairly simple equation to
solve i mean what do we have to solve
you need to solve
who
took what
so
you know so what makes this so
complicated
what makes it so complicated is a
complexity of the real world
let me just
show you what's what's really happening
so we have cameras we have fixtures
uh we need to send the data
from these
cameras and fixtures and we do it
through streaming services and we build
this just workout technology that
answers the question
who took what so for every item that's
being taken we answer the question who
took what
the result of it
uh
we need now to know
who
and what account to charge well we do
that at the gate the gate the qr code
provides a a payment method
and then
by adding
all the
individual
events
we create a virtual shopping cart
fit together
create a customer card and then we can
issue a receipt
so
let me talk about this uh just work
technology for a little bit
what is the what is the component what
is this well
turns out i probably could write a
textbook a computer vision textbook
using just workout as a use case
so what i see well first of all you have
cameras
and we need to know
where they are with respect to the to
the rest of the store and where they are
with respect of it to each other and
that's what we call calibration
now
we need to answer the question who
so to do that
we need to detect
uh
people customers so that's the role of
person detection
of course we need to know what
and that is the object recognition which
is a very mature field in computer
vision
in order to associate
the item
to the customer
we need
those estimation
and finally we need to know what happens
so
what is it is it a
tech activity is it a return activity
so
um
as activity analysis
and as i showed you you have multiple
sensors so you put all this information
together to generate a
a receipt that is sensor fusion so the
difference between a textbook
and the just workout technology is that
our algorithm must not just work
statistically
but
they need to be better than the state of
the art
okay
so
let's go through some of the the
complexity here
you know originally we thought
we only need to locate the customer when
they're shopping as a shelf turns out
we didn't get the level of accuracy we
needed and we needed to locate the
customer from store entry to exit
and if there is one customer it's easy
but when there are
lots of customers and it becomes complex
because of occlusion
and sometimes
they may appear to be
similar to each other so that's the
difficulty in there
so let me show you
a
a view a top-level view
of
the system in action
so what we have here
is a bunch of disks
each disks
represent
a a
identified
person
and we put a label
the idea is
we need to locate
this
this circle in every frame
and persist the label
so the green label right here such as d1
or e9 needs to be preserved during the
sequence so uh
we have the entry right here we have our
shells right here we have shells here
shelves there i'm gonna i'm gonna show
you
uh what is happening i want you to
specifically pay attention to this
one i7
um label in particular
i will also take a look at b6
so here it is
and uh you can see what okay the i17
turned yellow
when it turns yellow
is that we know
the presence
of the the the customer because we have
no trap doors and we have no
teleportation so
um
we know but we don't know precisely
where it is so we create what we call a
tangled state there okay so that's the
the the example
uh another difficulty here is that we
have many products in our in
in our store we have
ready to eat foods we have meal kits we
have beverages
some
are challenges because they are very
similar to each other so we solve this
with a combination of categorization
which is essentially indexing
and deep networks
for fine grain recognition
so we can recognize thousands of
products and we are we are robust to
illumination changes shadows reflection
which actually occur in the real world
so here are some examples of
uh products
that are very similar visually
but are different so that's a bombay
potatoes and chana masala are very very
similar but they are actually different
and on the right
is instead
the same product
which is
looks very different
due to
lighting or or
movement
okay so now how do we solve the
uh
association
between the product
and the customer is is done by
again a deep learning we find an
articulated model
and
here is a
a replay of
of a an activity where we have replaced
the
the
the actual
customer actions
by
the
interpretation from the system so we see
that
that is what our system understands
okay so where are we today with this
well we have
many stores
we have them in seattle san francisco
chicago new york we have also expanded
internationally we now have a
a
full grocery store
that is powered by jwo
and
we created this just workout experience
which pushed the boundaries
of computer vision machine learning and
sensor fusion along the way but
essentially we started with
what is the customer problem
and the answer is not obviously
just work out technology this is where
the quote makes sense
we take the problem you invent on behalf
of the customer and you provide a
a customer experience
which addresses this customer problem so
that was the first example
let's take the second example which is
amazon one
which was introduced
late
2020
so again
what is the customer problem we're
trying to solve here is that unlike in
the online world where you can pay with
a click
or authenticate
in the physical world this takes time
and it adds friction i mean you need to
go look for your credit card as this
person is doing here
or you need to fish for your phone and
you know it creates friction what we
want to do here is give customers
time back
and time is a
very precious resource so
let's start with a
uh
a quick
uh
video that explains
the customer experience right here so
let's listen
let's listen to zoe
this is zoe
just like you she uses lots of different
cards and ids to get through her day
what if all zoe needed
was herself
introducing amazon one a free service
that lets you use your palm to quickly
pay for things gain access earn rewards
and more
let's say you're grabbing your favorite
coffee beverage
or heading into the office
or checking out
just hover your palm and you're on your
way it's as easy as that sign up is free
and takes less than a minute all you
need is a credit card your phone number
and your palm that's it
since your palm is unique and can't be
lost or misplaced you can get things
done quickly and securely
and with more experiences on the way
amazon one will help you get even more
done simply by being you
now zoe has more time to do what she
loves indoor skydiving
enter identify and pay with amazon one
what is the customer experience in there
well
it is
safe it's easy it's convenient
to both to enter to identify to pay uh
first thing is that you're in control
each time you use amazon one
you intentionally need to put your
your your hand over the device to scan
your palm for it to work so you get to
decide exactly when and where to be
recognized
the second one is no two palms are like
it is a unique part of you so it doesn't
go anywhere you don't and it can't be
used by anyone but you
and finally it's a truly contactless
interaction
you once you have signed up
you never have to touch anything to use
it
so
what are the lessons here
the lesson is that
if you listen to customers
you hear about pain points you're not
hearing a solution
so again if i tell you i hate waiting in
line in the
in the supermarket
it doesn't automatically translate into
oh just work out okay so the invention
part is to come up with jw the same
thing
if you say well
it takes too long to authenticate
well that doesn't translate immediately
to amazon one this is where the
invention is
okay so
uh
now to get there to get from the notion
of oh let's do it let's invent
you need both dreamers and builders to
go from the idea
to the implementation and to turning
invention into reality
and you have to be stubborn on the
vision you know what you want you know
what is the customer problem you have to
solve but you need to be flexible on the
approach you need to explore in order to
get to the right solution
well
that brings me to the
end of my lecture here
uh the end of the journey is the current
journey
and i want to
close with this words right here that
uh
in terms of the computer vision which is
the area that i know
the the work i've been uh i've been uh
doing for 40 plus years
it is a golden age
why it is because computer vision now
works to solve real problems in
commercial application computer vision
is real
second
it is a wonderful sandbox for science
and engineering and this relates to my
comment about dreamers and builders
science and engineering you need to
create
the concept you need to develop it and
then you need to make it into a product
and there are many many opportunities
many opportunities not um
for research but startups
lots of startups can
leverage these advances in computer
vision
not just startup but large companies
that are making a significant investment
in computer vision and obviously amazon
google apple microsoft facebook all of
these companies are looking at computer
vision as a core technology
to invent
to reinvent the future
with that
uh i want to thank you for coming along
on this
journey
through
my career at
in the field of computer vision
and
i hope you enjoyed it thank you very
much
you